we can't allow tensions of problems
overseas to split over in lond them one
of the joys of our great cities are
diversity and for me it's a strength and
weakness and so I think you got to
distinguish the murder destruction and
actions of a pcri organization and you
how people behave in London that PR lies
in and there are people who are scared
in London that can't be right there are
people who because their place of
worship is a synagogue that insecurity
SED 24 hours a day 7 days a week because
the school their child goes to is a
Jewish faith school they require
security during term time because people
walk down the Streets of London and
they're Orthodox Jewish people that they
could be targets for this hate crime and
what we can't afford to happen and we
must not allowed to happen is there to
be an increase in pte crime in London
because of what's happening in the
Middle East